Technology came along
as a way to allow me
to achieve a balance
and to help me
get things done.
I am Rafaela.
I'm from Fortaleza.
I attended a Management School.
I've worked at multinationals,
mainly in Sales
and Marketing.
I had never considered
learning programming.
I've always liked logic,
and I've always worked
with MS Excel.
I was always that person
searching through the menus,
finding new formulas,
looking for more practical ways
to do things.
After working over 8 years
for several companies,
I made a decision
to start studying Technology
seriously,
coming along in large part
right now
because I'm pregnant,
because of the prospect
of becoming a mother.
That was when
I started thinking
I needed to follow
a new path
so I could have
a balanced life
the way I believe
I should have.
That's what I found
at Udacity.
Because it is online,
it's easier.
Being able to study
at home is great.
After I took the Intro
to Programming course,
my Tech studies
are not something I would
consider temporary.
It's something you get
interested in
and study more thoroughly.
Today I'm part of a network
of motherhood entrepreneurship
that helps women who want
to tread new paths
so they can discover a balance
between family and work.
Motherhood has a great impact
on a person's life and family.
Many women stop working
because they aren't able
to redefine themselves.
But when you apply
technology to it,
new opportunities
spring forth
and these women can assume
roles in the market,
where they held few positions
before.
It's like a switch flicked on
inside me.
I can start programming.
And I think that's empowering.